yeah this is antifreeze this was built
by one of our Katara firs that came into
the studio war holic and he didn't mean
like we love this map and it was it's
kind of a more of an infantry based beg
team battle map which is really fun and
where's you know less big vehicle
focused and so he built a lot of this
with a lot of snow in mind and so you
can see a lot of the rocks or the the
kind of ice pieces and then we like the
theme of anti freeze and thought about
like this kind of forerunner a structure
that was kind of in the middle of it and
that the snow is kind of encroaching
into this this giant forerunner
structure and so we kind of used that as
a theme as we built it out and cleaned
it up but like there were things that he
didn't have access to like these laser
shields before you couldn't do things
like go back like you couldn't change
colors and so we added a bunch of
details and so we did you know we used a
lot of this map to kind of just finish
off assets and stuff like that that we
needed to do or tweak and tune in so I
started building this one at home and so
I started this base over here and like
again you see it's like I wanted to feel
ripped apart in the snow and crouching
into the room as it builds out and then
as it bleeds into this forerunner
structure as its kind of taking it over
in a way and then there's big kind of
what we used to refer this is like the
cathedral because there was this big
kind of open area and there's some
amazing we have some amazing fights in
here like ground pounding from off of
this platform on to hear what people are
holding strongholds but yeah so you can
see like a lot of the consistent like I
was saying like themes like so there's
all that to spawn points and then even
our little strongholds has a little
stronghold marker over it and and that
just so that you know what everything's
going to do as you kind of fly around
the level like our flags have a flag
baked into them so that you can tail up
that's a flag and I can see how high the
flag is going to be when I'm running
around so there's a lot of language and
kind of designed going on behind all
this is we were building we wanted to
have these these grav lifts in here but
we didn't want them to look like
forerunner UNSC gravel asst we wanted
this area to feel kind of like
magical almost in a way so we made
invisible gravel it so that you can just
walk in they'll kick you up and there
you go you know so it's a lot of little
things like that just a little again
little taking toys that we already have
like a grav lift and like well make an
invisible version that makes a little
more interesting I can bury that into a
ramp and nobody it and maybe light it
differently so it has a cool feel and
then you hit it and it does something
different like it changes your gameplay
and it changes your expectations and it
lets them really customized the crap out
of what they build which is super
awesome I think this map school they
like each base has a slightly different
theme to it like this one's a little
more clean and like even just doing
things like this kit bashing these
pieces together to make this cool little
bit that you can kind of thrust awful it
was kind of fun right just experimenting
with shapes we want again real a
forerunner II theme with this kind of
map really angular type stuff and a lot
of this is just with our primitive
pieces we actually didn't have we don't
really have any particular forerunner II
kind of assets in here we started with
kind of more units c-type theme stuff or
and then primitive pieces but like you
can build stuff that looks very
forerunner II and then you know like oh
let's play with the colors to make that
pop out differently or you know like
play with shapes
so you can see it yet so a lot of
forerunner weapons to keep that theme
you know we like themes it makes I know
it makes things easier to build two
degree like once you start thinking
about the story behind the map like I
came up with the idea that like this
side is like the dark like there's some
sort of dark energy in that room and
then and so we put this little light in
here you know with a effect on it so you
can see it pop out and then the other
side was more good and so that just in
my head that's basically what I built
off it doesn't actually mean anything I
don't think this is going to go into
cannon at any point soon but like it was
kind of fun to help build the lap level
out and like because it was so like
snowy centric and then once we started
thinking okay the one side is very snow
centric because it's kind of bleeding
into the level from the like kind of
evil or bad and then over on this side
it's more it's clean and pure still and
so it's kind of fun to use that now both
sides the map have distinct call out
locations and you can feel which side of
the map you're on when you're playing
the I don't I think that's the fun of
forage is that like really anybody can
do this and like that's one thing that
like people will when we launched some
of the BTB maps people didn't like some
of them and like or they have issues
with things and like you can fix that
you can change that you can use that as
a starting point and just change weapon
placement if you hate weapon placement
if you want to like rebuild a whole area
go nuts like weird that's what we want
you to do so we're just going to keep
giving you everything we can to let you
do that but this maps got all kinds of
cool little areas there's little caverns
underneath
the lead you know back out into the
central game play spaces and then
there's that kind of grab lift down
there and then this more snowy cave
theme again just playing with themes and
like using the different pieces to build
the areas to feel differently and then
yeah this is the only vehicle we have on
here but it's really fun because it's
it's it's basically like having a fast
infantry in the level and then they get
ground pounded especially when they
these things start moving into that
central structure which is kind of what
happens because there's some really cool
vehicle lanes through here and the
fighting would get chaos and like it
would focus really a lot around this
central area and the ghost would come in
and just get rampaged by the people
jumping a ground pounding off of those
things it's cool though but yeah I mean
it just shows like kind of what this is
kind of what a final map would look like
if you built a big team battle map and
this map pretty much pushes to the edges
of our object limits like it's I know
Adrian who took it over after i left it
because i was like there was a point is
like i have to go finish forage i can't
really focus on the baking battle maps
and so my friend Adrian started working
on it and he started obsessing on
details too and like pushing it to the
object count limit and then we'd have to
like delete some carefully so we could
get the name locations in so that the
name locations are like when you're
running around the level we find one
here so this is like when I'm in this
area it says I'm in red yard and so that
all those things we have to those
currently take up objects and so we have
to be very careful about how you kind of
balance these things out when you're
building things and like some of these
pieces like we built a lot of like
especially the primitives and stuff we
built those or out sourced a lot of that
stuff and then towards the end I was
going through campaign and war zone and
be like what do I want to steal like and
then I have to you know kind of horse
trade with our lead artist to be like
okay I would like these hundred pieces
and he's like oh my god you're going to
create so many more bugs and more
content we already have you know 1600
objects do you really need more and my
philosophy is yes you always need more
but I mean like these pieces were come
some struts that we stole from I think
war zone and then repurpose them and
then they didn't have they weren't as
kind of closed up and clean as they are
we had to close them up so they could
work from every angle in forage like
grab that piece so you can see that pace
again that's that kick bashing thing
like we that's how we build everything
in forage and it's I know it's I think
it's fun it's a really because you can
find so many different uses out of
everything like like these are these are
our shield emitters that we because we
wanted our shields to look like they
belong to in the environment so we made
things that snapped onto those and like
oh we can use those as lights and like
make for run or any kind of feeling
structures with them so it's that kit
bashi multi-purpose thing that I think I
love so much about building in forage
and it leaves that I know it's really up
to your imagination at that point which
is cool
you